so men i think are often fed this
narrative that masculinity is inherently
toxic which i think is it can be very
damaging but then they go out onto the
sexual marketplace they go out to a bar
they go into an app and it's the guys
who are stereotypically masculine which
tend to be doing better when it comes to
dating so it throws up this kind of
cognitive dissonance like what is going
on here
why is calling the dating market the
dating economy a good term
um i'm not sure it's a good term i mean
it's it's it seems very um
it seems slightly brutal to to look at
that dating romance and and our ideas of
romance to turn it into some kind of
economic exchange um
but i think it can be useful i think it
can be a useful way to
it can be a useful metaphor for some of
the things that are going on in in the
world of dating i think it can be a
useful metaphor for people who aren't
in that dating market at the moment say
older typically older people who are
married or who grew up in a very
different era when very different social
norms prevailed i think the idea of
a dating economy uh can be a useful way
to convey to them some of the
inequalities that exist now and that's
and and the final point really is with
dating apps you have actual data
um on what men's women's preferences are
so it it that can that can be put in
spreadsheets so it's kind of uh
it's kind of an economy yeah well you're
hearing more
sort of economic language around this
stuff now
people are scored out of 10
you have algorithms that are
manipulating people's
ranks on
dating accounts
there are like sexual market value is a
term that's often used in men's right
spaces around the relative age to
attractiveness graph that goes on so it
kind of it kind of does make sense and
yeah
i suppose communicating it to people who
found their found their partner a very
long time ago they need something to be
able to bridge the gap between their
dating world and ours which is
essentially a different universe
yeah and i mean there is a dark side to
it as well though i think there's
there's a dark side to
um
treating it as an economy and and
treating it in this very like
deterministic fashion
um quantitative fashion where
you you ascribe these certain
characteristics to someone say like a
chad so like the the good looking chad
guy
and
that
you know that's the person who who who
gets with women and then this other
person who doesn't look the right way uh
doesn't you they have no chances over as
some of the insults say i think that
kind of determinism
can tend to creep into it um when it's
seen as like an economy whereas in like
in reality
like dating is it's not you know a
market where there's certain laws which
exists it's it's
there's there's nuances aren't like
someone doesn't um
yeah it's too simplistic to too
deterministic i'd agree so since 2008
the number of american men under 30
reporting no sex has nearly tripled why
do you think that is
i think that's more than one factor of
course i mean i think the the most
obvious one the historic one would be
the shift from like a monogamous culture
to
what we have today which is today is i
wouldn't call it hookup cultures day i
think today is a mixture some people are
very engaged with dating apps and
hookups but i think a lot of people do
still um want to pursue like a more
traditional route but i think that
that's one big change so
whereas in the past you had you lived in
a small community
um you tended to pair off with someone
suitable for you um women didn't have
the same learning power they had so
women were more restricted unfortunately
in like who they could um choose to date
because the tenants have to marry who
their family approved of because from
financial reasons and so that'd be the
first reason that's not that that
culture is no longer really
as strong as it was in the past so
women don't need to settle down with men
they're not attracted to basically um
the second
reason i suppose i think dating apps
have made a big difference because
and when i say dating apps i also mean
apps like instagram um because i think
this idea that the
how you present yourself is also is
almost more important than the your
substance as a person so like if you
know how to present yourself properly
um i think you can do really well in in
today's like dating economy even if you
don't necessarily have the attributes of
the the child or whatever
but i think um if you most people don't
don't know that i don't think and um
that makes it very hard for them to kind
of when when more than 50 i think of
people who young couples who get
together nowadays it's they met on a
dating app so if you don't know how to
present yourself through a screen if
you're not photogenic
if you can't convey things like status
or
good looks or whatever resources um
social dominance or whatever over a over
a
photo or a profile i think then you have
a really hard time and so
um you're in the house looking at porn
because that there are easy alternatives
as well so to kind of satiate you so you
don't need to go out and
uh risk rejection
more than fifty percent of couples met
online
yeah it's it's it's you you'd assume
that anyway now i think because i mean
anyone
that i met my girlfriend on on hinge um
my friends they're they're the people
they're meeting it tends to be on dating
apps it's there's still vast stuff you
still meet people in bars and stuff
until the pandemic but it's apps are
just an easier option
[Music]
yeah it's an interesting one man
thinking about what that means what that
does to us as a
as a society i think that you're right
this kind of this desire to be able to
understand everything creeps in from
other other areas right so science tries
to explain the entire world in terms of
concepts and then we want to be able to
add that sort of deterministic
reductionist rationalist perspective to
dating as well okay so what am i out of
10 what height am i at how many matches
have i got on tinder where do i sit in
my sexual market value all of these
things seem to sort of coalesce
yeah and it even going back to say like
the the pickup artist in the so neil
streisa the game in like 2005 i think it
was and um
even around that kind of scene it was it
kind of was really about
nerds basically socially awkward men
trying to
put the kind of treat it like
engineering treat it like treat it treat
dating like you're an engineer or you're
so you know you put this wire in here or
you press this button and then you get
this response and kind of quantify
everything and removes the like
uncertainty because the pain is in the
uncertainty isn't it when you when you
first go out with someone when you first
approach someone to start a conversation
or something it's it's a fear of
rejection is you know terrifying so if
you can kind of
quantify everything so
uh you can
uh figure out you know if you take this
move then then this outcome will happen
or it gives you a rationale for just
giving up so within cells it's uh
i think there's a there's a kind of
misanthropic uh
aspect to some of it where
you kind of
you kind of self-flagellate yourself and
get something from that and these
doctrines like the black pill tell you
oh it's over you know there's no point
even trying and there is a kind of a
weird freedom in that you know just like
legitimately
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the world you know
or not in this case [ __ ] the world
what do you think it says that
a lot of the guys that were part of that
fratire pickup artistry community 10 to
15 years ago
are in really weird places now so neil
strauss
has had the biggest 180 ever and seems
to be sort of super happily married um
that mystery guy
i don't know where he's going that roosh
v he's now like a born again christian
or something tucker max the guy that
invented fratir the entire frati genre
he's now uh
like a
paragon of mdma psychotherapy and went
to psychotherapy every day for five
years and now he's
self helping people to self-publish
books like david goggins what do you
think
that says is that just guys growing up
is that just mistakes that you make when
you're single and then the wrangling
effect of a relationship or is there
something else going on there
i mean different different for different
cases so i mean i think different things
are going on and there's also you know
the big part of the what used to be like
the pickup community is now in moved
into like self-help and and
um personal development of
you know a spiritual
supposedly like a spiritual kind of
transformation and stuff um i think
the one reason i think this happened
so i mean i've seen people
from that that old community on videos
you know doing anti-vaxx stuff as well
and that kind of thing now you know the
calling it the plan they're making
things like that
um which i think i think part of that
comes from an initial distrust of the
mainstream so if we go back to say like
2005 when when neil strikes published
his book
the reason one of the reasons like lots
of men were kind of drawn to
the the picker by stuff i think um and i
would you know when it first came out i
was interested in this you know i i
sucked with
just social skills in general when i was
like 22 23
and i think a lot of people got drawn
into that because what the mainstream
told
young people and men and women
about romance was kind of you kind of
started to see through it as you as you
reach your kind of team's early 20s and
you know it didn't just happen you know
fate didn't take care of it uh
being nice you know being a gentleman
being chivalrous a chivalrous gentleman
it wasn't uh
you know the girls it didn't weren't
interested in you like in college or
whatever and it was the you know it's
the cliche like the guy who was
kind of a dick who seemed to ha who
seemed to be the one who who got with
the with the attractive girls
and
not necessarily because he was a dick
but there was there was you know other
things going on there but i think lots
of people who got into the pa at pua and
pick up stuff they saw this mainstream
narrative
you know heard their parents telling me
just like be nice and you'll meet
someone and it they just saw right
through it and then there was the void
there and then the kind of pickup artist
stepped in and said you know
this you know they they actually said
that some of the dating is
counter-intuitive um like flirting for
example um but there was this toxic side
to all of that too
um and i think um
i forgot we've kind of forgotten where
i'm going with this but where's that
what why have we seen these people from
there
pivot into these incredibly sort of
different
lives you know only 10 years later
yeah i mean i think yeah distrust of the
mainstream so you've seen that kind of
that their whole trajectory from pickup
to like self-help to some of the
religious like
weirdness that this guy rich v i mean he
was a very toxic example
right the way through uh in my opinion
so um but i think the distrust of the
mainstream has has propelled these
people into different
um cults basically um and and part of
that is because the mainstream does talk
rubbish on dating advice and i think
pickup and was was sort of a reaction to
that um even though you know it was
itself quite toxic in many ways you
spent a fair bit of time last year
speaking to people on a podcast about
the modern dating economy what were some
of the more surprising insights that you
weren't ready for during your research
for that
um i suppose
i mean
i've always been kind of optimistic by
uh people's
potential to like self-improve in some
ways like the average but average person
i know people have different problems
and stuff but i think um
yeah someone someone of like average
looks average kind of abilities can like
go to the gym and like improve
themselves a bit and
things will get easier in terms of like
dating
um but i suppose
speaking to people on the podcast there
was there was a couple of conversations
where
i kind of i spoke to
someone about lookism i had a
conversation about lookism what's that
so it's it's discrimination based on
what people look like so we all we all
do that in in dating but it's it's it's
kind of across other areas so you know
you earn less over a lifetime if you
um
uh uh
stereo uh stereotypically less
attractive and you earn more of a
lifetime if you're
stereotypically attractive um i kind of
learned more about how how deep that is
in society how deep the kind of
how deeply we we often treat
how differently we often treat you know
stereotypically good looking people from
from those who aren't so so fortunate in
that way and also you know i think a lot
of the advice to given to intel's can be
condescending when it comes from that
kind of self-development self-help space
so
i had a conversation with william
costello who's done some writing on
research on on in sales and he you know
he's recorded that one of the things
that's most often said to in cells is oh
just lift just lift bro you know go to
the gym and that'll solve your problems
and um
you know just just go out to the bar and
and if you're the pickup artist told
them to just go out to a bar and just
start approaching but then
there's a bit of kind of arrogance to
that because we don't understand always
this is some of the issues that some of
these people are going through so you
have people with physical deformities
you have people with you know 20 20 i
think of people on the in the intel
community
uh have have aspergers or high
functioning autism um
so i mean
just telling someone to go out to a bar
um and socialize or go to the gym is you
know sometimes it's harder for those
people
yeah that was what came up speaking to
nama
on the podcast as well that
the languages in the worlds that people
different people exist in
they don't work anymore the pieces of
advice that previously we would have got
from our parents or from modern dating
doesn't understand but then as you get
more and more nuanced they don't
understand the challenges
either
there was another one that i thought was
really interesting talking about the
differences between men and women
17 of young people think approaching
anyone
is harassment but also 90 of women want
the man to approach first how can those
two things exist at the same time
yeah i mean there's a weird kind of um
cognitive dissonance dissonance in the
culture generally i think when it comes
to dating at the moment so that's one
example where um you have a
thing is i mean
that that's 17 or whatever that's like
people they're all online because it
seems like that's if you're on twitter
or something um and you even suggested
you know approaching someone you were
interested in just you know in a bar or
something
or you know coffee shop or whatever they
would say that's you know borderline
harassment already this is weird but
then if you go out into into the real
world i mean people are still meeting
like that people it's still it's still
happening but there's this weird like
discourse online which pretends um with
scolds anyone who would dare to to do
such a thing um i think that's i think
there is a
there is an issue for men in terms of
um met so so men don't often perceive
how uncomfortable they make women feel
they often don't um
there was a recent book by david david
bust the
yeah
he was amazing yeah his his work is
really interesting and his book bad men
uh he talked about you know the the kind
of empathy gap where
if a woman's like approached by by these
creepy guys then the men doing the men
being creepy will often not
understand that they're being creepy
there's this like empathy gap and uh
they don't understand how uncomfortable
they're making women feel so i mean i
think there are there are i think
there's a backlash against that and
women are kind of demanding in many
cases not to be harassed or even talked
to in in the public kind of space um but
but i think there's about there's an
obvious balance like um there's a way
there's a way to go and start a
conversation with someone and there's a
way not to do i think common sense is
like most people outside of the kind of
twitter weird ideological tower ivory
tower
understand what's creepy and what's not
at least on
one level um but yeah there's this kind
of weird uh ideological cognitive
dissonance at the moment
it is strange because i i understand you
want to
you don't want to get people into a
situation where they're made to feel
uncomfortable nobody wants that no one
and last of all as a guy you don't want
to be the guy that makes someone feel
uncomfortable either
but
on the flip side 90 of women want the
man to approach first and this is
something that keeps on coming up
desire and the market always kind of
manifests everyone's truth forward so
for instance when companies talk about
social justice activists talk about
perhaps um let's say the the perils of
fast fashion but i can't believe that
these companies are
selling these clothes for so cheap and
they're damaging the environment and
they're hurting the workers but then
when you look at what those girls wear
on their nights out they'll happily go
on pretty little thing and grab
themselves address for 10 pounds
so the market always seems to kind of
find where people's real truths lay and
then the same thing seems to happen in
dating too that in some ideologically
pure environment where we try and nerf
any discomfort out of the world yeah
maybe
there are situations in which maybe the
safest world that we could exist in is
one where no man ever walks up to a
woman because that means that no woman
can ever be made to feel uncomfortable
but it also means that most women are
not going to feel like they're desired
and desire is a really important thing
so yeah you do have these sort of
conflicting ideologies bouncing up
against each other
yeah and i think there's there's it's
very hard to have a conversation about
inequalities in the dating quote-unquote
market is it i find this very um
hard to have conversations with when
it's with people who haven't
like studied this in some way or who
haven't taken an interest in it so
they're just looking at it from like a
personal perspective i find with guys
there's like a lot of guys have a lot of
ego
around um
around this stuff so you know they they
may have met their second significant
other you know in and out in an
old-fashioned way like through through
college or through work or something
um
but then they believe that you know if
they wanted to they had the so they have
the social skills to go and meet you
know in a bar just walk up to someone
and talk start a conversation whatever
and so they kind of sneer at the in
cells and and
um you know throw the insult in cell
around everywhere um to kind of show
that they're superior to those people
whereas if they were in the same context
in cells there are now um that you know
they just literally got lucky in in that
situation and so there's kind of an ego
attached to
discussing uh some of these things i
think
women are reluctant to discuss
um
like dating inequality partly because i
think there's a legitimate fear of
a regression to some of the kind of
socially conservative norms
of the past the one that in particular
the ones which which which didn't give
women much freedom because you know it
sought to control their sexuality i
think there's there's a fear on the part
of women to just kind of
look at dating inequalities because
there's an aspect of that which feels to
them like um we're blaming women for
their choices you know for not choosing
the nice the nice uh the nice guy who
works in insurance or whatever um but
for like for like going off with like
chad who has a motorbike um i think
there's an element of um
because i think that's too deterministic
as well but i think women fear um
that conversation taking center stage
because then you then get a movement
which tries to put women back into this
box uh where they don't have any sexual
freedom at all yeah
in a world where inequality is quite
in vogue
and and applauded at the moment why do
you think sexual inequality is one of
these ones that just isn't apart from
the
desire of women not to be put back into
a sort of a trad world which is
perfectly legitimate
i think i think partly because like
what's the what would the remedy be i
mean there is
i mean there's the remedies are
individual so the remedy if you're so i
mean
the remedy if you're someone who's like
struggling
uh to if you're if you're a guy who's
struggling to get any kind of date or
anything i mean
there is really no other remedy than
kind of individual work on yourself in
some ways like or just focusing on other
things so
so welcome yourself you know basic
self-improvement stuff i think kind of
holds true like go to the gym get some
hobbies improve your social skills and
like find ways to start talking and
conversing with people so you say your
social muscle that builds more i mean
and also i would say just like focus on
other stuff because uh
i think one of the problems is
there is a kind of so that the when the
feminists talk about this issue what
they are right about is uh
the the way men treat each other based
on how many people the
how many women the man's had sex with
it's like we hold men in much higher
esteem
typically or culturally if they're seen
as someone who you know um
has you guessed with women or whatever
it's it's you know you'll see and
whereas if you're not you're insulted as
you know the platform the playground age
it's like a virgin or an intel night
and i think um
if men i think men kind of have to move
away from that value system a bit
because it's it's it's quite um there
are lots of problems with it but one of
them is if you if you happen to be at
the lower end of that hierarchy and
you're attaching so much value to the
fact that so you're to your
ability to to
get in a partnership or whatever you
think that that's the be all landlord of
life i think that that makes it worse i
mean there is there is a there is
something to be said for you know
focusing on some vocation or whatever
instead and and then funnily enough
paradoxically i think people are more
attractive when they do that as well
they gain status they become
uh more attractive people because they
have
ambition and drive and whatever
it's
it's a weird one because
i think a lot of women judge other
women's looks more harshly than men do
because they're able to see the finer
points of that dress with those earrings
and those nails are [ __ ] or whatever and
then men judge or the men's status and
resources and sexual conquest now the
consequences are more important to the
other side because that kind of gets to
work out where you are hypergamously
within the hierarchy for each different
gender but a lot of the discomfort
actually gets delivered from your own
side right you get the the pain about
not pulling or being a virgin or an
incel or whatever from your own side
more so from the other and the same
thing goes for for looks with women that
a lot of the criticisms i think that
women have around beauty standards for
women
the finger needs to be pointed very
heavily
at women for creating these beauty
standards for each other
yeah i mean i i i think there's kind of
an element of of interest intersexual
competition so like pulling other women
dying and men do it as well just in you
know different way they they they berate
them for for kind of different different
things
um and try and kind of um
subvert that kind of masculinity and
belittle them
for that but i think it's
um i mean i i think there's
we we've come from like an era where
there were where there were all these
norms around um you know marriage and
the nuclear family and many of those
were quite quite sexist and stuff
and now you've got you've got the kind
of residual memory of that so you've got
a generation above us
um who who that was completely normal
and and and those attitudes they still
pass on to the to their kids and stuff
and um we have a more liberal which i
think is generally a good thing uh
sexual climate now where the same ideas
are kind of um transmitted to young men
who aren't very successful that you know
oh if you're if you don't um if you
aren't finding someone to settle down
with or if you aren't sleeping with all
these women you're basically a loser and
a virgin and an insult
i think that's uh i think that's yeah
that's incredibly toxic and i think
that's um and
an app like instagram and and whatnot
where you see the rise of influencers
it's like double zerion
it's um
it kind of elevates even more this idea
that the the kind of the really
successful man is the person with with
like a harem of of women or whatever
that politionist and you know that's not
necessarily a very good idea for the
women either because they're they're
treated as kind of uh props in that in
that scenario
what are some of the challenges that
women have in the modern dating market
i think the the age-old one of
threat of violence so
um the risk so i know going out on on a
date with someone new for for us saying
on like an app or something
we it wouldn't really cross our mind
that's that like our head can end up on
a stick at the end of the night or
something it's like there's that that
wouldn't even like i wouldn't even think
about that generally you're not bothered
about whether she's putting something in
your drink yeah i did have a stalker i
do but i do kind of have a stalker so
it's i probably shouldn't say but it's
still it's um i don't think the fear of
physical violence isn't isn't like the
same um so no i think that's obviously
for women that's that's the biggest
challenge i think also
now you have on on dating apps there's a
level of inequality so there's a like
the data we have is like a relatively
small percentage of men like 10 20
um whatever it is tend to be the ones
getting most of the matches and then the
average male is is not not doing that
well uh you know just just just a few
matches
and
i think for for women on the one hand
that's good because they're now they
have a wider pool of people to kind of
shoot their shot at so if you're a woman
on a dating app um you could actually
try you can actually start a
conversation with the highest status guy
who maybe lives in the city when you
live in the country or whatever
and you can at least have a shot at that
but i think it can be
bad for women because i think they then
get used by a lot of those those those
men and not necessarily like women can
enjoy you know casual hookups with as
much as as much as men and and that's um
yeah i mean that's that's um i think
when we get society is beginning to
accept that more now but it's also i
think they
often date these guys in the hope of a
relationship and then the guys string
them along and then they end up kind of
using them so i think um women can get
the raw end of the
can get a raw deal um
yeah across the board it seems to be the
chads who do the best the social chats
who do the best out of the dating app
economy there's only them
that have won as far as i can see so
yeah i would i would agree and say that
more choice for women more liberation
fewer judgments around sexual
sort of freedom yeah those are good
things
but as women become higher status better
educated with more resources they want
to date up and across but as men can't
keep up with the women that are now
starting to outperform them the women
all they really have left to do is to
have an ever increasing group of women
competing for an ever decreasing group
of high performing high status men or
to date someone that fundamentally
they're slightly less attracted to and
if you've been through the dating pool
on tinder and you have had a hookup or a
couple of hookups with these super high
value men
you're now you've got this sort of
comparison game going on where you think
well this was this is what i got before
therefore i can get it again but the
paradigm within which that worked like
it's hookup versus relationship and then
that creates resentment amongst some of
the guys as well i've had comments on
previous videos from people saying that
it's the duty of guys to young single
guys to find a woman at 22 or 23 and
settle down with them
because going through a
laundry list of girls you know every six
months or whatever throughout your 20s
is effectively tying up their
reproductive capability uh so that they
they aren't this is monogamy as a sexual
redistribution strategy right like that
if it's one man to one woman then it
enables more men to have sex with more
with the equal number of women that they
have but um
yet a challenge man this whole thing's
got so messy and who would have known
you know he knew that downstream from
women being able to quite rightly
learn as much as they want and earn as
much as they want and
move up within organizations and gain
status and buy houses and do stuff like
that most women don't want to date a man
that doesn't work i think you this was a
stat i learned from you that only like
10 or 15 percent of women would ever
consider dating a man who's either
part-time employed or not employed at
all
um all of these things are challenges
all of these things are really difficult
yeah and i think there's there's a
question of
both men and women
recognizing certain i don't know i mean
as much as this is i hope this is
possible but men and women kind of
recognizing certain
biological like drives in terms of um
finding someone of higher status or a
man you know being attracted to
you know like a 40 year old man you
still pursuing
you know 25 year old women or whatever
i've got i've got some friends that are
like that yeah
yeah i mean there's there's kind of um
there's kind of two
there's there's kind of some things
which
which we know kind of there's a tendency
towards so so if you there's surveys
with like men from the ages of um you
know 20 to 40 or whatever
they the age of the women they're
attracted to stays around the same it's
like it doesn't so when they're in their
20s like 23 year old women or when
they're 40 it's still 23 year old women
or whatever but it's like it doesn't
mean you have to actually do that it's
like it doesn't mean
it's it's morally a good thing for
someone who's um you know a married
person to just keep trading in for like
a younger partner there's something kind
of very shallow very immoral immoral
about that um and
there's something you know our society
in general it kind of reflects something
in our society in general where
everything is seen as like disposable
including your you're saying other way
you just throw it away and kind of buy
it essentially buy like buy a new one or
replace it with something newer and
shinier in many cases of these people
yeah probably is buy buy another one um
but i think it doesn't mean you have to
actually like live that and the culture
i think makes a big difference as well
and for women um it's you know
yeah
like there may be an aspect of biology
which kind of um
moves them towards pursuing
the highest status
man in the community or who's accessible
but is that always the should it should
the culture encourage that or should it
say you know there are other values that
are important as well because i think
those things do make a difference it's
gonna be hard to make don't go for
like you don't deserve the best like you
know this whole kind of worth it yeah
you're not you're you're worth slightly
less than you think you are is like the
message to take from that but there's
this whole sort of don't settle no
settling clapping back be a boss [ __ ]
these sorts of things don't
lend themselves toward
women being accepting of of challenges
with a partner and if you have finally
managed to get a guy that is of the
right status with everything else i
don't know if you can culturally i don't
think that the layer the layering of
completely
um ridding us
of
how do you say evolved cultural wisdom
that
a a single relationship be attractive to
many partners but choose one
dispensing with that whilst also saying
that you should get whatever you want
i think that these two things provide a
very difficult dating market
specifically for women more so than for
men i mean i think we're moving the
other way as well so it's i think we're
still moving in the opposite direction
where
um
where you know it
we're not moving
back towards you know more monogamous
culture we're moving more to a place
where
i think social media is an interesting
one here
in terms of how it's like expanded the
dating pool so
um if you have an app like instagram
um
for like say a relatively attractive
woman who lives in like a small town or
something um if she
gains some kind of instagram client
she's going to have access to a much
wider pool of men
you know low-key celebrities and whatnot
than she would in you shouldn't have the
blue ticks like sliding into a
into dms and and whatnot so she's now
got access to to those potential
partners in a way that she like didn't
wouldn't have had in the past um and i
think that's as technology kind of
increases it's the the purpose of
technology in our economy now is to kind
of
um create more choice for us to to
expand our choice potential
um and so
there is a there is kind of
encouragement to kind of have it all to
pursue the absolute top thing um but
also the what's considered you know
status or high status a lot of that is
conditioned by the culture so
if we look at good looks for example
there's a start from so i think every
decade since the 1930s
um every decade no not every decade
since the television age uh people have
attached more status to good looks in a
partner than previously so every decade
since whenever tvs were went like mass
market
um people
you know you you they're attracted to
certain good looks but it's also their
status attached to looks as well why do
you think that is
because i i think you know uh
presentation so so
if you move from an economy where it's
print-based to where it's all on a
screen you have the rise of politicians
like jfk for example
telegenic charismatic um
and i think that that that means then
status becomes attached to those those
qualities and that feeds over into
dating as well and i think dating apps
have
accentuated that even more so
when i was when i was coming up
in the mid 2000s as like a teenager and
early 20 something
you know i i wasn't i wasn't doing very
well with the uh with the opposite sex
at that time but there was i was never
worried about something like my height
like i'm like what five five eleven i
think but it was never like oh you gotta
be six foot or something like that that
to me is something that's been it was
always there a little bit but it's been
kind of um formalized from the culture
around dating apps and i think the same
is true about certain types of good
looks so
um the importance of being good looking
the status attached to it
is more now one because things happen
through a screen often the first
impression but also because because
women have more economic independence so
um can freely choose more they don't
have to necessarily think about how much
money the person has
if they're attractive if they're
physically attractive are there some
intersecting groups of feminists at the
moment
i don't really understand how
all of feminism is
fragmented but i imagine that some
groups are kind of happy with the
direction in which things are going and
others kind of want to turn things
around have you looked at any of this
um i mean yeah i mean i don't think
anyone's i mean
i guess with activists no one's ever
happy with the direction things have
gone i mean going because otherwise you
still become an activist and what the
hell would you do with your time then if
everything is everything's fine already
um you sound like a neo neo-liberal then
but um no i think
i think yeah it varies so i mean sex
positive feminists tend to see
uh
hook up culture as you know sexual
freedom is broadly a good thing
and in some ways i think i think they're
right i think it's um
i think you know i i i adhere to the
basic kind of principle liberal
principles on that i think people should
be free to kind of get get together with
who they want um the radical feminists
it tends to be more of a
there's there's more of a kind of
anti-pornography campaign and
anti-prostitution campaigns going on at
the moment i think is um
yeah again i i agree with aspects of
that as well i think um i don't think
it's inherently good just like the
commodification of people's bodies and
and the idea that there's the
pleasurable that there is in life i
think there is like a deeper
a deeper reason to be with someone for
example
um and then you have like the
traditionalists the the trads the trad
uh the the trad wing of the feminist
movement which is um just just like
appalled by everything
but yeah but that's their role i suppose
but but they're but but then they're not
completely wrong either i mean
i think there's uh as we've talked about
i think many women get a raw deal from
from hookup culture
um i also think um
yeah i think there's something to be
said there's there's kind of a deeper
meaning
uh to to being with someone and just
like gratification i think being
building like a connection building a
deeper bond building something um
meaningful i think is i think there is
an importance that i'm not i don't
subscribe to the to the whole
um
you know progressive thing that
you know
is ostensibly anti-capitalist but yet
treats other human beings as if they're
completely like disposable when you can
just swap one person out for someone
else i think sometimes uh
it's it's much there's much more kind of
value to be built in building a longer a
bigger connection
it's like that story of the blind men
and the elephant isn't it it's
some of them everyone's touching a
different part and someone has got a
little bit of truth within their own
different domain
yeah man so i'm really really fascinated
with what we see next
like what happens how we move forward
from this position with
sort of increasing sexual liberation but
a biological compulsion to have a family
you know you have to be no matter how
culturally deprogrammed you think things
need to get you have to be an incredibly
unique man or woman i think to make it
to 50 without a partner or a family and
say look back and say that it was a good
a good decision that's not to say that
there aren't people out there for whom
that is correct but to make it to that
stage you are an outlier like by
definition
you would have been your genes would not
have made it through so that is that is
by definition an outlier perspective
but it seems that finding families and
creating families
is going to get more difficult i i don't
know if you agree
yeah i mean i think some ways the kind
of it
aside from the kind of um
the the actual incels or whatever i
think that the kind of dating
environment now it can also create like
a
uh like an uh aura like a halo or like a
penumbra of insecurity around uh
existing relationships because there's
so much choice potential on an app on
could have always done a little bit
better you've got it in the back of your
mind yeah so there's stats in one of
david bost's books again which is talks
about how
um when we're exposed to a partner who's
who's more attractive than than
than our other
when we're supposed to a partner who's
someone in the meet social media who's
more attractive than our partner
we we tend to become you know someone
asks us questions about them we tend to
give less committed answers to this
partner so oh you know it's not that
serious or whatever there's there's
quite big studies on this and when works
and our satisfaction goes down with our
current partner so when we're exposed
all the time to these
um images of so-called perfection many
of them not even real many of it's you
know many of them are
airbrushed and and edited and whatever
are kind of we've we the same we feel
the same way we do with our work or
whatever that you know the grass is
greener on the other side that everyone
else is living this amazing life while
we're
you know our life
is a real life you know it's not perfect
like even the people on social media you
know that that's not real but but
there's his perception that is real um
at least to some extent and we feel more
dissatisfied with our current products
so the environment now with social media
i think it creates this bigger area of
insecurity around existing relationships
as well makes that more like perilous
should i get in a relationship because
um you know there's more opportunity to
cheat i mean like one in three
what does it know it's like 25 i think
of men on tinder have
partners already like girlfriends and
wives or are married it's uh
it's sort of shocking in a way there's
like more opportunity and yeah more
opportunities to cheat wasn't there uh
you interviewed a lady on your podcast
he went for a date directly opposite the
apartment block where the man that she
was on a date with lived with his misses
and his misses came down and started
shouting at them
yeah yeah i mean and and that's the
thing i think men for men i think they
should speak to women more about their
experiences on dates because
i mean every every woman i've been out
with in in the last
like couple of years i've i've kind of
been curious and talked about their
experiences and dating apps and they all
have like a super weird story whether
it's like a weird like catfish story or
or um
yeah things like that where someone's
someone's married and then hides it and
or just like worse where it's someone
who's creepy or pushy or something like
that but um yeah it's i mean the
internet allows people to conceal um
conceal their intentions a bit more
what's porn doing to dating
i think porn's making men more like
apathetic to get to kind of go out there
and try and make the effort to meet
someone because it's you know it's um
i think that's kind of common sense
really i think that's that's fairly
obvious that
if someone has the
i think going out to meet new people
especially so i was someone who's very
socially awkward when i was uh
so from like 17 to about 22 i didn't
have a girlfriend that lived in in the
countryside
had like a lot of social anxiety it was
very um
i would say introverted shy so i would
be afraid to
i could not imagine going and having a
conversation with with a woman or
something
and i think
um if you're in that situation i think
it's there's already
so much fear around going outside and
stuff and you're just kind of um
like pornography is another reason to
kind of stay in it takes care of one of
your basic needs in the way that
computer games will stimulate you or
there's there's one less reason to go
outside to find simulation to find to
like engage with the world it's like a
simulation of the world i think that
that's a big thing and also i think it's
the view of women there's the obvious
points about
i think um
you see the prevalence of of men uh
treating women in a certain way um in
the bedroom because they've seen
something in in like a porn film and um
they they don't they they aren't
calibrated so whether the woman is is
you know that's something they're
enjoying and it's and then
uh yeah i mean you hear lots of stories
from women about this in the media like
the pawnification of sex i think that's
a problem
and um
yeah i mean and and just the standards
so so people
think that this is the certain sound of
beauty what they see in in like a porn
film it makes guys feel insecure on the
one hand so
they think if they're not the guy in the
porn film who they don't know is you
know taking like some viagra or whatever
and um on steroids and
everything else they they think that
like that's the standard they have to
live up to now so it makes them get like
anxiety and for women it's like they
feel the same way sometimes about the
porn actresses that men are that's the
kind of women that men desire so you
have to look up to that i think it can
be very harmful um yeah
i mean i'm not sure
what i think would do about it in terms
of like um policy or like whether it
should be restricted or anything but i
think it can be very harmful what about
porn and sex addiction you had a
conversation about this right what do
you find out there
yeah i mean i think um
so i have adhd so i can get basically
easily addicted to anything anything
stimulating
um
but
yeah i mean it's with kind of um
i'm not sure
if i believe really sexually sex
addiction but
i think it's more like dopamine
addiction isn't it so it's kind of
i take medication because there's like a
lack of dopamine in my brain and the
medication fills
the dopamine gap in the
neurotransmitters so i mean if you
um yeah i mean we all like a dopamine
hit so i mean that's what sex education
is in a way just that on steroids or
something yeah they looked at your
guests looked at the pathways i think
and couldn't find any similarities
between the sort of typical addictions
that people were finding
with
drugs and and that from
porn or from sex but as he said i think
it was tiger woods that used as the
example
if you lose your night contract because
you've cheated on your wife that's one
thing but if you've lost your night
contract because you've got an addiction
then you go to rehab and come back out
that's
something quite different and you're
able to get your sponsorship back right
i think yeah
yeah i mean my girlfriend accuses me of
using adhd as an excuse so it's like i
can't help it i've got ideas i've got a
medical i got a note from the doctor
yeah what about only fans what do you
think that's doing to men and women's
views of each other
i mean i think it's it's
like i think it's a sad situation but
not not in kind of a prudish way so i
mean i don't really feel like
like shocked like oh my god these these
people are kind of um
you know doing this stuff like online
it's more just like first of all because
i think there's an economic critique of
it where
women feel like the the most valuable
asset in society is to just take their
clothes off
for thirsty men basically but then on
the other hand you've got
i think the situation on on the part of
many men is quite sad as well because
with only fans it's not always just
pornography i mean you have
men trying to form
intimate connections with
with their quote-unquote girlfriends
um
and we'll regularly see the same
same hebrew limits the women who've
women who've talked about this often
have talked about how
um the men also want a conversation and
wants some kind of connection with
someone that they don't have in in in
the real world so i mean i think i think
those two things are quite kind of
depressing kind of comments or
commentaries on the like atomization of
society i think there's something else
going on here with regards to women's
views of men
as purely
commodities or purely sort of a wallet
to open up and i think that this
trickles down you see this
in young girl culture or at least i do
in nightclubs that
girls are happy to bounce from table to
table in a nightclub that's what i do i
run nightclubs and you see the girls
that'll move between the different
tables and take drinks from whatever and
they'll stay on the table that's got the
most bottles the biggest one you think
well yeah so part of this is just old
school hierarchical resource acquisition
and trying to get the guy that looks
like he's got the most state is because
he's got the most the biggest table with
the biggest bottles
but i also think there's something else
going on which is that
when
women are able to make
astronomical amounts of money you know
six figures a month
from
commodifying
themselves but taking the money out of
the pocket of men quite rightly there's
an argument on one side that says well
men have been the gatekeepers for wealth
for far too long and women are able to
take this back and you go well yeah but
is it
is it your highest virtue to to do it at
sort of the lowest most base level of
what it is that you have to offer the
world like you know prostitution's as
old as time but
and that's not to say that doing sex
work online is the same as prostitution
but it's not a million miles away you
know
it's not a million miles away and i
think that
there's this quote from a buddy of mine
who said that um
just as porn is impacting men's opinion
men's
expectations of women-only funds is
impacting women's expectations of men
and that um
you mentioned it a couple of times
transient transactional sort of
relationship what can i get out of you
for what you want from me it does seem
to kind of encourage that
commodification of relationships
yes definitely and i think i think
there's
there are feminists i think who have a
good critique of the only fast
phenomenon in the
like you may you may go on to like only
fans and if you're a attractive woman
and make far more money than you make in
in your regular job
but you're also helping to perpetuate a
culture where a woman's value highest
value is seen just as her physical
attractiveness so
you you're you're kind of um you're not
helping the sisterhood so to speak i
think that's a good
a good critique of it from a feminist
perspective that you're you're helping
to perpetuate this standard social
standard where a woman feels often feels
like her only value is how attractive
she is which does obviously harm women
in the long term you know because
they'll they'll
you you see this the the the
quote-unquote shelf life of
um women in modeling or or you know
music career or whatever um or you know
in the in the the red pill communities
whatever they talk of women you know
over
35 is hitting the wall and
um but you know it's it's it's an
unpleasant term but it it speaks to how
women lose many of their opportunities
in our society when they lose their
physical
beauty and and
you know i think
only things like only fans perpetuate
that idea that a woman's a woman's value
is attached just to her physical
attractiveness yeah you are right
there's a an episode with heather hang
and brett weinstein on rogan it was the
first one they did together years ago
now and they asked everybody to try and
imagine
somebody of the opposite sex who is
beautiful but not hot
and then someone that is hot but not
beautiful
and the distinction that they made there
was that a lot of modern culture
especially media magazines instagram
so and so forth they're signaling off
hotness not beauty and hotness wanes
with age whereas beauty can either stay
stable or appreciate with age you know
you think of someone that's got grace
and poise and they've kind of got this
timeless sort of look to them that stays
over time as opposed to someone that's
hot which is kind of quite obvious and
in your face and it's very much sort of
that instagram style and um
yeah again with that like i i said this
uh with a surprisingly low amount of
kickback from the internet that if
you're a woman who's made it to 30 and
your primary source of value is still
your looks then you need to be quite
careful about how you spend the next
five years
because
that is typically that is only going to
go in one direction no matter how much
cosmetic surgery you get and if that's
you need to have something else think
about an investment portfolio if you had
an investment portfolio and 100 of your
investment was in one particular stock
you'd think well
i probably could be a bit more hedged
here i probably could spread my risk a
little bit more effectively and the same
thing goes with with girls like there is
a [ __ ] litany of personal development
stuff out there for you so you can
become
spiritually comfortable with yourself
outside of it you can gain confidence
you can you know do whatever it is that
you want to do
but only fans
allows
the race to the bottom of the brain stem
to perpetuate
yeah definitely i mean i think the the
um
on the one hand the the the the
superficial standards in a way of i
think also
what social media does and what the apps
do is they create this kind of archetype
of someone who's attractive both for men
and women and it's very crude so
so i think
i i i think it emphasizes like the chat
or it puts people in these boxes like
you're a child or you're you're a loser
or whatever
whereas i think um in the in the real
world it's
like what people are attracted to it's
not like a conscious choice and i think
it's way more way more complex i mean
someone could not be like the quote
quite nine or ten in like looks or
whatever but they can be a very
charismatic person they can have a very
magnetic perspective i've got i've got
some really ugly mates that crush these
girls that absolutely crush it with
girls you think well you wouldn't have
got picked up on the app but then
like every single night they get swarms
of girls around them because they're
funny or charming or whatever
yeah it's like they have the the cool
vibe or whatever and they give off that
kind of aura of of being cool i guess um
if that if that isn't too vague but i
think social media gives this idea to
um men and women that there's kind of
one type of look one one version of
success in a way and then i think it's
it is quite easy to get disheartened by
that because we're bombarded with
we're on our phones you know all day
we're bombarded with these images
constantly and
this idea of what the kind of the so
whereas once we were bombarded with the
idea of what the the the normal life is
the monogamous nuclear family whatever
pick it white plague events now we're
bombarded with this idea of what's
attractive um and if you're not living
up to that again women have had this for
years you're not living up to that you
should feel bad about yourself but i
think it's also men are subjected to
that similar pressure uh now as well
like if you're not the chad if you're
not these things then
um
yeah you you're kind of screwed
that's not really true yeah what's
happening with consent at the moment
because i remember
a little while ago
maybe sort of two
two to five years ago there was all of
this sort of consent pawn floating
around and these weird
um you must ask before you
say hello you must ask before you touch
your massage before that what's where's
that at have you have you seen any of
this stuff
i mean
with with that stuff i mean i think that
stuff
will i think that stuff will always hit
the roadblock of
um
like
in terms of like people there's a joke
about you having to sign consent forms
before you you sleep with them and stuff
i mean that's never going to happen
because that isn't anyone that isn't how
it goes down that isn't just isn't how
it goes that isn't how it happens and
i don't think that's how most people
most women would want would want it to
happen like that either but i do think
at the same time i i absolutely do think
that
like there is a
a lot of education to be done among men
in terms of
again if you if when i've spoken to
girlfriends
people have dated about their
experiences from from dating apps and
whatever
they all have one story of some some
pushy guy who doesn't pretty much all of
them have some story of some pushy guy
who doesn't accept no for an answer
um so there's something wrong in the
culture i think that
that's still something women have to
face they don't feel they can report it
they don't feel like they can uh
necessarily come forward about that i
think there's there's two things going
on i think the attempt to formalize it
through
you know
um
affirmative consent written consent or
whatever is i think that's ridiculous
but i do think there's um there needs to
be
more repercussions for men who who
don't you know who do push push the
boundaries and and don't accept no for
answer but i also think men need to be
that there is a there is a kind of rape
culture
um to some extent i think in certain
like fraternities of men
i think there's
there's
i mean there's kind of a an assumption i
think among someone that you know
um
[Music]
yeah i mean i heard from the pickup
community years ago that
you know women have some women have rape
fantasies so
um there's like it's okay to kind of to
push it and and you know no means you no
just means not yet and this kind of
stuff which i think is that's very
dangerous to be telling um
especially socially uncalibrated or dark
triad dark triad men this kind of
information they they would feel like
they have a free pass to sexually
assault someone
but i just think there's
in terms of just from speaking to like
female friends and stuff like i feel
like there is
an assumption among some men that they
can just keep pushing it and there won't
be really any repercussions um if they
do that because
um few women would actually do want to
go take these things further
um
yeah man i mean i
that makes me that makes me really
uncomfortable the fact that pretty much
every girl that you know and i think a
lot of the ones that i do as well have
had a situation where this happens
i wonder
so david david bus in that bad man and
anyone who hasn't read it needs to go
and check it out because it's [ __ ]
awesome read
he talks about the fact that most men
aren't like this but you have a small
minority of men that complete the
majority of offenses
and um
yeah the danger is that you nerf
relationships to the stage where all of
the excitement which which comes from
the the uncertainty right like the
reason that people get excited is the
fact that she doesn't know
if you're actually interested or not and
you don't know if she's interested or
not like that's where the spark comes
from at least in part
and if you get rid of that
you know with even if you decide against
having the the form and the fingerprint
id to say yes i want to have sex
if you do have
enough to get rid of that excitement
again desire will always win out and it
you're going to lose so i don't know how
much you can
culturally
sort of get rid of the of the real bad
actors you know if you've got someone
that's narcissistic psycho psychopathic
and high in machiavellianism like i
think those people are just going to
[ __ ] the game no matter what i don't i
don't want to call anyone a lost cause
but kind of just feel a little bit like
that
yeah i mean i don't think you ever like
eliminate
you know the the propensity of a segment
of people to try and take advantage of
you know people try and take those
people who try and take advantage of any
situation you know if there's money
there they would see that if there's
they feel like they can get away with
sexually insulting someone they will do
that yeah i mean i think that's that's a
police matter basically but i do think
there's i mean i do think there's an
onus on on
the rest of us as men to kind of call
that out when we see it you know i i do
think a lot of men are good at this
already like i do think there is that
kind of
um you know in the street or something
if
people see someone
hassling a woman men often will step in
um and and and intervene i think doing
that i think can be can be a positive
like if your friends is acting in a way
that's sleazy or whatever like calling
them out
i also think men learning basic social
skills so it's being socially calibrated
so that
uh so as david bust says in in his book
is so they have more empathy from the
woman's perspective she knew asking your
female friends how does it feel when how
you know what was this experience how
did that feel like to you like because
you you know i've been with with a a
girlfriend in like a bar or something
and someone's approached and i just
thought it was like a normal
conversation and she was like he was
really creepy and it's like asking why
because i think our men and women you
often don't see the other person's
perspective totally different worlds
yeah we exist in different planes
yeah dating stuff so i think that would
be that'd be something like we we can do
um as kind of guys in that situation
i've definitely seen
a big
change
in the way that young guys
talk about relationships and girls in
general and sort of the culture
so
i've been in lads chats of one form or
another whether that be like blackberry
messenger bbm pin back in the day
or whatsapp chats for kind of the last
10 years or so running club nights
constantly having young guys in there
who are at university who are liberated
sexually who have
parties and girls on tap and hearing the
sort of language and seeing it come out
of myself as well and you know like
the the
movement over time where the overton
window of acceptable speech has shifted
from and to perfect example of this we
used to have um cards that all of the
boys had to have in their wallets at all
times
and it said um you're fit come to voodoo
and it was a free entry pass but we
could they could only give it to girls
and there was another one that said your
mint come to skin so that was a bit more
cheesy um and someone posted it in one
of our group chats today and said look
what i just found in an old wallet
and uh a bunch of people said [ __ ]
hell mate you wouldn't be able to do
that now wouldn't be able to have
wouldn't be able to have that now and it
is a little bit tongue-in-cheek but the
fact that you have people who aren't
culture warriors they're not bothered
about keeping their finger on the pulse
of the [ __ ] bleeding edge of what's
happening with
ideology and identity politics and
intersectionality but they are aware
that there has been some sort of a
reckoning
that has happened you know whether it be
me too whether it be jimmy savile then
sort of trickling down to the epstein
and the weinstein and so on and so forth
they're aware of that and these are just
[ __ ] salt of the earth dudes who are
now in the late 20s
looking back on their time at university
and realizing
wow
times have changed in the period of less
than 10 years
yeah i mean i think there's kind of a
i mean yeah i mean i think on the one
hand there's there's i think it's good
that these these bad guys have been
exposed those people getting away with
so much for so long um in terms of how
they're treated women i think it's it's
good they've been exposed but i think
some of the
the media kind of interpretation of some
of this stuff is a bit
overblown um on
from both sides so i think
the there is this idea propagated on uh
progressive social media that all women
just walk around in fear of being
assaulted at all times um i think that's
an exaggeration um but i also think that
the kind of um
there's a there's an aspect in the of
the kind of manosphere if you like which
which exaggerates how much how difficult
it is to go and start a conversation
with a woman nowadays because oh you're
going to be accused of of sexual assault
or something it's like people actually
know who go out and
um do um date and and go on date stuff
who who are socially calibrated and and
aren't like weird they don't they never
have these experiences these issues
really because there is a sweet spot
where it's like just be cool
here's what i keep on thinking
i keep on thinking that the vast
majority of people making these comments
about the real world only exist on the
internet
but because they're the loudest voices
on the internet people like us that
exist in the real world as well that
maybe sort of have one foot in either
and straddle it are like [ __ ]
dude did you hear about
did you hear about the fact that 17 of
people don't want it it's like yeah but
those 17 of people don't leave the house
that's the 17 of people that have never
had anybody come up to them ever
and i've got yeah
sorry karen just i've got a friend who
is a very [ __ ] well-rounded young guy
uh and i was out with him not long ago
and he's he reiterated that to me
he said that to me he was like dude like
you know i've sort of could do with
getting a bird at the moment i'm going
through a bit of a dry patch or whatever
and i was like oh man like you know
there's the chicks over there and chicks
he's like no man you can't go up and
talk to someone like you know it's
dangerous i don't say you are
you've spent too much time in the
internet my friend you've spent too much
time on the internet yeah
that is that is a good example i think
of like twitter mind or where
um so i i try not to use social media
too much because on the one hand you've
i've got you there's instagram where
it's like this idea of perfection in
terms of photos and then on twitter it's
this um
that it can be this like weird activist
space where any kind of social faux pas
people like a load of obsessives who are
just on there all day will jump on it
and uh and take it tell you to shreds
and that's happened to me like a bunch
of times um
but then yeah if you go out if you go to
a bar or something or if you just go out
into the real world or if you know i i
have tried to have friends not in that
space
so not engaged in politics not on
twitter all the time and when i'm with
those people it's i just remember it's
like coming up for air i remember that
actually
uh in the real world it's it's um
yeah common sense tends to prevail and
people have a reason fairly reasonable
idea of how to approach these situations
again yeah there's the percentage of
people who don't but um i mean i
wouldn't be friends with those people
anyway so
what about masculinity do you think
obviously there's been a bit of a
reckoning like masculinity's been a
an analogy or it's been under the
ancillary end of of this reckoning
around me too and men in positions of
power using that to get themselves
access to sexual access and abusing it
and stuff like that but it does feel at
least to me like
that's left a bit of a void for
masculinity that men are now struggling
to try and find a
society acceptable wholesome but also
desirable
masculine
cliche for them to
erode for them to walk down
yeah i think it's i think there is like
a lot of um it is kind of it's like a
cliche to say it but it is a confusing
time to be
a man particularly a younger man i think
in many ways within the culture because
on the one hand
you're you're fed this narrative that
masculinity is toxic and
i mean so i've even i've even read
things about um so yesterday i was
reading something and it talked about
how
gym memberships have gone up 40 between
2015 and 2018 or something and when i
read that i thought that's great that
means more people are taking care of
themselves as because we have an obesity
problem so it's a good thing if more
people are joining the gym but it was
framed as this kind of toxic obsession
with the self and um then i've seen it
framed as you know toxic masculinity and
yeah i mean it can be of course if when
it
goes to a certain point but generally
it's like a positive thing to
uh work out so i like i i find it
somewhere i can switch off from the
writing and
meet a different kind of uh crowd of
people that i've made throughout
journalism and it's just like it's just
that it's just a great um
a great environment to be in it's loads
of positive positive things come from
that but it's framed as like toxic and
you know toxic masculinity um so so men
i think are often fed this narrative
that
masculinity is inherently toxic
um
which i think is it can be very damaging
but then they go out onto the sexual
marketplace they go out to a bar they go
into an app and it's the guys who are
stereotypically masculine which tend to
be doing better with um when it comes to
dating so it there's it throws up this
kind of cognitive dissonance like what
is going on here so when i was in my
early uh late teens early twenties i was
into like emo and
uh punk music and stuff where it's not
the most like masculine dudes like um
lamenting their loss like sweethearts
and stuff and i i
i absorbed and vibed the idea that that
was how
that you should put your weight your
heart on your sleeve that's how you uh
that sounds like a that sounds like a
taking back sunday song or something
doesn't it
yeah i mean i'm sure there is a song
from that
genre
entitled that but i thought that was the
way you kind of
like that's the way you this is the way
you get girls you like dye your hair
black and white like nail vinyl should
be like uh sensitive like sensors jared
leno jared don't get to birds man
but then those people have status though
so that's what i was misunderstanding so
if they're in the world famous like emo
band they have status so they can dress
as a you know a chocolate chip cookie
and they'd still get laid um but it but
it was um
but but the reality like if you look at
the the like the evidence like i went
out a lot i spent a year i spent a long
time at university and then i was in
vegas for like a while and i was going
out a lot and you see what what what how
it goes down really you see the people
who these the women you find attractive
go home with and it isn't the sense of
nice sensitive emo guy
it's the
uh extroverted socially dominant
whatever
not always the chat necessary just the
person with the status in the
environment say the club environment for
the person who has the dj the dance
floor table whatever um and i think that
confuses that was really confusing to me
um as a man because it's like i felt
like i was being lied to by the
mainstream
progressives were lying to me and saying
that
it was just a blank slate and men and
women just want the same things
and even the mainstream itself was still
wedded to this old style old-fashioned
narrative that just don't worry about it
you'll meet someone and fate will take
care of it like in the hollywood film
where the nerd
the nice man the nice fellow gets the
woman in the end so i think it's very
confusing both of those things but there
hasn't been
as far as i can see a
solution there hasn't been something new
that's come through to fill that void
it's like yeah
i can accept everyone can accept should
be able to accept that men using status
and resources to get abusive access
to sex in return for them doing
something in the workplace is like
[ __ ] reprehensible
but we also have to concede that there
are certain elements of masculine energy
which are inherently attractive to women
okay
so you've thrown the the baby the bath
water and the [ __ ] bath's gone out
the window like what are we left with
yeah i mean so yeah there is a
contradiction in the lamenting the on
the one hand it's you know we lament the
abuse of men in powerful positions
exploiting that position too i don't
mean like weinstein weinstein
necessarily because that that's that's a
rape situation but
i mean
where men in
high-powered positions um use that
position to
get with younger much younger women much
more attractive women than they are
and and that's kind of everybody is
exploiting everyone in some ways and
again i'm not talking about harassment
or
or or things like that but it's like
you often have have the the women who is
who are going to these nightclubs say in
that environment just to find to these
tables to find the high status men
because they will benefit economically
and increase their own social status if
they're on their instagram yeah and then
the men the men are using their own
leverage their status that finance is
there even just their contacts in the
club like in vegas you you also had a
layer of
uh entrepreneurs in that respect who
didn't have any money
but would still be on that have these
these amazing tables because of
connections and stuff which is quite
interesting but then because they have
the status they would now kind of um
they would now meet more women than they
would if they just stayed in that usual
economic role so i mean everyone's
exploiting everyone in in some respects
i i think it's the
we don't really hear that because
everything today is framed as like
oppressor oppressed
and it's this binary whereas in some
situations yet people are getting
different things out of the situation
yeah it's too simplistic
to split things off like that it just
yeah it doesn't doesn't take in any of
the nuances of of
of of human beings basically the you
know men are not not just like this and
women are not just like this but
sometimes we are selfish sometimes we
seek to improve orion status sometimes
um
yeah and and and
no one's inherently virtuous like
there's like blessing russell's quote
about the fallacy of the superior virtue
of the oppressed it's like i agree that
women have been oppressed by
a kind of patriarchal
structure superstructure for
much of the last kind of few thousand
years but
that doesn't mean that there aren't you
know that doesn't mean that they're the
all men are bad men are trash or
whatever and that women are inherently
virtuous it's obviously more complicated
than that it's the same theme that i'm
seeing with pretty much everything that
sort of social deconstructionists that
want to completely upend absolutely
everything
are doing it at such a pace that we
can't work out which is baby and wishes
which is bath water it's like look did i
need that bit of society that nope too
late it's gone it's in the incinerator
[ __ ] i might have wanted that that we
might it might have been religion might
have been useful but there's there's an
increasing number of people that are
cultural christians now because they
[ __ ] long for
a a weekly service with people from
their local community that helps them
feel or and a connection to a higher
power but we threw that out of the
inside okay so let's throw out of the
window masculinity let's throw out of
the window the
all of this stuff and we should do that
with our peril man because [ __ ]
having to reinvent all of the [ __ ] that
we already discovered
is
it's a real [ __ ] on and it's highly
inefficient
yeah and there's an arrow into it as
well that
i mean it's very um
so we we see our society now and think
that we'll just prevail forever you know
we can throw as much [ __ ] as we want um
but he'll just be fine you know we'll
always live in a liberal democracy we'll
always be able to but he's like no you
can't actually
throw enough on it and then it it's
deposed for something much worse where
you no longer have the freedom to
criticize that that system
um yeah i mean i think the i think we're
a place now where
um
the west is kind of denigrated and and
like i i have many crystals of of
like capitalism for example but i think
i was i feel very relatively lucky to
have been born in in this country
to grow up here i don't feel
um and i grew up working in a working
class home i wasn't someone from a
privileged background but i still feel
relatively fortunate to
grow up here and and there's a there's a
weird deconstructionism around
um gender roles in specific specifically
so i mean
on the one hand you know i think gender
is natural inertia i think there's many
roles that women have been pushed into
for the advantage of men so that
um you know
for the service of men basically but at
the same time
i find it it's really weird to me that
the main narrative in like liberal
politics is this blank slate
ideology where
there's no such thing as masculinity and
femininity it's all a social construct
because i feel like at the same time
everyone knows in their dating life
that that's not true because there has
to be some polarity there you're there
there's the old like thing about
opposites attract you you're
there's
um
there's there has to be this polarity
there it's like you know what femininity
is as
a heterosexual man i know what feminism
i may not be able to describe feminism
necessarily but i know it when i see it
like that that famous um
that famous quote and i think most women
it's the same but we have to we pretend
otherwise i think because
i i i don't know i think because if we
acknowledge that there's these things
that are inherently different people
fear that then
um you know it won't be different but
equal it would be different but
therefore you must you must if you're a
woman you must stay in the kitchen or
you must uh stay at home whatever and i
think that's um
yeah i mean that's inevitable though
isn't it because for in a recent past
that was what men use that information
to do they use the differences between
men and women to oppress women
danger of overshooting man really really
got to be going to be careful with that
stuff but james bloodworth ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with what you're doing where should
they go
uh so you can follow me on instagram at
james.bloodworth
um and also twitter is jay underscore
bloodworth awesome cheers dude cool this
is fun thank you thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace